though there
are exp potential explanations for the
fermi paradox and one of them that i
kind of like is that
the truly intelligent creatures are
those that decided
not to colonize the whole galaxy because
they'd quickly run out of room there
because it's exponential right you send
a probe to a planet
it makes two copies they go out
they make two copies each and it's an
exponential right they quickly colonize
the whole galaxy but then
the distance to the next galaxy the next
big one like andromeda
that's two and a half million light
years yeah that's a much grander scale
now right
and so it also could be that the reason
they survived the salon
is that they got over this tendency
that may well exist among sufficiently
intelligent creatures
this tendency for aggression and
self-destruction
right if they bypass that and that may
be
one of the great filters if there are
more than one right
then they may not be a type of creature
that feels the need
to go and say oh there's a nice looking
planet
and there's a bunch of you know ants on
it let's go
squish them and colonize it no it could
even be
the kind of star trek like prime
directive where you go and explore
worlds
but you don't interfere in any way
right and and also we call it
exploration it's beautiful
and everything but there is underlying
this desire to explore
is a desire to conquer yeah i mean if
we're just being really honest
right now for us it is right and you're
saying it's possible to separate
but i would venture to say that
you wouldn't that those are coupled so
i could i could imagine a civilization
that lives on for billions of years
that just stays on his like figures out
the minimal
effort way of just peacefully existing
it's like a
monastery yeah and it limits itself yeah
it limits itself
you know it's it's planted its seeds in
a number of places so it's not
vulnerable to
a single point failure right supernova
going off near one of these stars or
something or an asteroid
or a comet coming in from the art cloud
equivalent of that planetary system and
without warning you know thrashing them
to bits so they've got their seeds in a
bunch of places but they chose not to
colonize colonize the galaxy and they
also choose not to interfere
with this incredibly prevalent primitive
organism homo sapiens right
or they uh this is like a
they enjoy it's like a tv show for them
it's like a real
tv show right so they just tuned in
right so those are possible explanations
yet i i think that
to me the most likely explanation for
the ferryme paradox is that
they really are very very rare and you
know carl sagan estimated a hundred
thousand of them
if there's that many some of them would
have been way ahead of us and
and i think we would have seen them by
now if there are a handful
maybe they're there but at that point
you're right on this dividing line
between being a pessimist and an
optimist
yeah and what are the odds for that
right if you look at all the things that
had to go right for us
yeah and the then you know getting back
to something you said earlier let's
discuss
you know primitive life yeah that could
be
the thing that's difficult to achieve
just getting the random molecules
together
to a point where they start
self-replicating
and evolving and becoming better and all
that
that that's an inordinately difficult
thing i think
though i'm not you know some molecular
cell biologist but just
it's it's it's the usual argument you
know you're wandering around in the
sahara desert
and you stumble across a watch is your
is your initial response oh you know a
bunch of sand grains just came together
randomly and formed this watch no you
you think that
something formed it or it came from some
simpler structure that then became you
know more complex
all right it didn't just form well even
the simplest
life is is a very very complex structure
even the
even the simplest prokaryotic cells not
to mention eukaryotic cells although
that transition
may have been the so-called great filter
as well maybe
the cells without a nucleus are
relatively easy to form
and then the big next step is where you
have a nucleus which then provides a lot
of energy
which allows the cell to become much
much more complex and so on
interestingly going from eukaryotic
cells
single cells to multicellular organisms
does not appear to be at least on earth
one of these great filters because
there's evidence that it happened dozens
of times independently on earth
so by by a really great filter
something that happens very very rarely
i mean that we have to get
through um
an obstacle that is just
incredibly rare to get through
you